ISSUES.
>> THANKS A LOT FOR THAT
SUMMATION.
IF YOU WATCH THE COVERAGE OF
THIS STORY TODAY ON TELEVISION,
YOU LIKELY CAME AWAY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT JULIAN
ASSANGE'S I'M KIND OF RUSSIAN
SPY WHO IS IN TROUBLE TONIGHT
BECAUSE HE STOLE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS FROM THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS NOT TRUE, IT IS
FACTUALLY INCORRECT.
SAYING SO IS NOT A DEFENSE OF
ASSANGE, WE ARE NOT HERE TO
PROMOTE HIM OR EXCUSE ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS HE SAID.
BUT JUST SO IT IS CLEAR, HE DID
NOT STEAL DOCUMENTS FROM THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
HE DID NOT HACK THE DNC SERVERS
AND DID NOT BREAK INTO THE
JOHN PODESTA EMAIL ACCOUNT.
HE'S NEVER BEEN CHARGED WITH ANY
OF THAT AND WASN'T TODAY, NO
MATTER WHAT THEY TELL YOU.
IF YOU ARE UPSET ABOUT THE THEFT
OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FROM THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT AND THERE IS
REASON TO BE, WE ALREADY KNOW
WHO DID THAT.
AT 22-YEAR-OLD ARMY PRIVATE
NAMED BRADLEY MANNING, NOW NAMED
CHELSEA MANNING.
HE GOT 35 YEARS IN PRISON.
SHORTLY AFTER THAT, BARACK OBAMA
COMMUTED MANNING'S A SENTENCE
WHICH ALLOWED MANNING TO LEAVE
JAIL DECADES EARLY, AND THEN RUN
FOR POLITICAL OFFICE.
AND STRANGELY NOBODY IS.
INSTEAD THEY ARE FURIOUS AT
JULIAN ASSANGE FOR PRINTING THE
DOCUMENTS THAT OTHER PEOPLE
STOLE.
HE WROTE BEN SASSE WHO ALSO
SERVES IN THE U.S. SENATE.
HE DESERVES TO SPEND THE REST OF
HIS LIFE IN PRISON.
WICKED?
SPEND THE REST OF HIS LIFE IN
PRISON?
I MEAN PEOPLE HAVE NEVER FACED
THIS KIND OF SCORN.
SO WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
FIRST, JULIAN ASSANGE PUBLISHED
DOCUMENTS THAT UNDERMINED THE
DOCUMENTS ON THE IRAQ WAR.
HE HUMILIATED HILLARY CLINTON BY
SHOWING THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARIES
WERE IN FACT RAVED.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON HAS
REASON TO HATE JULIAN ASSANGE.
BUT RATHER THAN ADMIT THAT
FORWARDLY MADE US LOOK LIKE
BUFFOONS.
HE SAID WE ARE DENOUNCING HIM
AS, YOU GUESSED IT, A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
>> JUSTICE SHOULD COME TO JULIAN
ASSANGE FOR HIS ROLE IN RUSSIAN
MEDDLING IN OUR ELECTION, THE
SOONER THE BETTER.
ONCE AGAIN TO BE TOTALLY CLEAR,
NO ONE HAS EVER SHOWN THAT
JULIAN ASSANGE IS A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
THAT INCLUDES MANY REPUBLICANS.
ROBERT MUELLER NEARLY KILLED THE
RUSSIAN COLLISION HOAX AND
JULIAN ASSANGE IS ALLOWING THEM
TO KEEP IT ALIVE.
YOU WOULD THINK JOURNALIST WOULD
SAY SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
ASSANGE IS AFTER ALL ONE OF
THEM.
WHAT DO YOU CALL A MAN WHO
PUBLISHES NEWS FOR A LIVING?
HE'S DEFINITELY NOT MORE
ANTI-AMERICAN AND HIS BROKEN
STORY IS THAT NEW YORK TIMES
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      P
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      L
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      T
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      E
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      S
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      F
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      U
WOULD HAVE ONE POLITICALS      .
OH PLEASE, BROUGHT ALEXIA
CAMPBELL.
WE KNOW WHO HE WORKS FOR,
MEANING RUSSIA.
JULIAN ASSANGE IS NOT A
JOURNALIST, WITHOUT ACTUALLY
EXPLAINING.
THAT DOESN'T SO MUCH GOVERN THE
NATIONAL SECURITY STATE ASIDE
FROM WRITE MEMOS ON HIS BEHALF.
MANY BELIEVE THAT IF ASSANGE WAS
EVER A JOURNALIST, THOSE DAYS
ENDED A LONG TIME AGO.
IT MEANS THEY BELIEVE IT.
SO WHY THE HOSTILITY TO JULIAN
ASSANGE?
WE WILL LET JIM PSEUDO-EXPLAIN.
HE IS CENTRAL TO CENTRAL
ELECTION EXPERIENCE, AND HE
CENTRAL ALSO TO QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OR
TRUMP CAMPAIGN NEW PRIOR TO THE
RELEASE OF THOSE MATERIALS.
>> IT'S REMARKABLE TO WATCH,
IT'S BILL ORDERING, ACTUALLY.
THAT WAS ALSO WHEN THEY DIDN'T
APPLAUD THE ARREST OF JOURNALIST
PUBLISHING INFORMATION.
IN 1971 "THE WASHINGTON POST"
AND "NEW YORK TIMES" PUBLISHED A
TROVE OF STOLEN CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ABOUT THE VIETNAM WAR
WHICH IS CALLED THE PENTAGON
PAPERS.
LIBERALS LOVED IT.
BOOKS WERE WRITTEN
THEIR BRAVERY.
AS EARLY AS 2011, THEY SAID IT
"A CONVICTION OF JULIAN ASSANGE
WOULD CAUSE COLLATERAL DAMAGE TO
AMERICAN MEDIA FREEDOMS.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO DISTINGUISHED
ASSANGE OR WIKILEAKS FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST," AND
THAT'S TRUE.
BUT THAT WAS BEFORE THE TRUMP
ELECTION AND THE TOTAL WAR THAT
FOLLOWED, A WAR IN WHICH THE
MEDIA HAD DEFINITIVELY CHOSEN
ASIDE.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT, THAT ALL
DEPENDS ON WHO YOU VOTE FOR.
THE GUARDIANS OF SPEECH ARE NOT
THE ENEMIES OF SPEECH.
THE PEOPLE CHARGED WITH POLICING